president biden says he is considering
allowing troops to help bring us
citizens throughout kabul to the airport
to get them there safely britain and
france as we've reported have already
sent special forces to assist their
citizens and allies in afghanistan
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin has this part of this carry out
rescue operations even though british
french and german paratroopers are doing
so but one brave american unit did
rescue
169 americans stuck just outside the
airport at a taliban checkpoint we've
also learned that a marine from the 24th
marine expeditionary group lifted this
afghan baby to safety delivering the
child to medical personnel the baby was
reunited with his father new details are
also emerging about this evacuation
flight from sunday
823 afghans not 640 were squeezed onto
this rescue flight due to the quick
thinking of airman first class nicholas
barron the load master and lieutenant
colonel eric coote who flew the plane
they said there was no time to worry
about seat belts we saw what needed to
be done to deliver hope and freedom we
knew the capability of our aircraft and
what we needed to do it safely and
effectively with all the crew members i
had i had the utmost trust in them to
get it done and to make sure that we
could get them to save passage president
biden said today the u.s has no national
interest in afghanistan look let's put
this thing in perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al qaeda gone what is
your current estimate for
how many al qaeda are inside afghanistan
i haven't seen an estimate on that
okay i don't know we have an exact
estimate military intelligence estimates
about how many al qaeda remain in
afghanistan we know that
al qaeda is a presence as well as isis
in afghanistan and we've talked about
that for quite some time we do not
believe it is exorbitantly high but we
don't have an exact figure for you can
you explain why
there's no national interest in afghan
afghanistan why did we have troops there
for 20 years if there's no national
interest in afghanistan we had a
significant interest in being in
afghanistan to our national security 20
years ago
and brett we've just learned
new details after being told all day
that u.s troops were not leaving the
airport did not have permission to go
and rescue americans
inside
kabul or outside of kabul we've just
learned from the pentagon press
secretary that three chinook helicopters
carried out a rescue mission about 200
yards from the airport where 169
americans were stranded at a building
they rescued those 169 americans and
brought them into the airport they are
now safe back to you
you know jen quickly you know we saw
defense secretary austin i guess
wednesday say we don't have the
capability to go out and collect up
large numbers of people is it possible
that it may start happening and we don't
know it
well you always have a possibility of
mission creep anytime you have u.s
forces on the ground and what we're
seeing is that there are any extremist
cases and when you have troops there and
there are calls for help it's going to
be difficult for them to say no if
they're american citizens
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else